You have the final say of who you allow
to join
your country, who you allow to be woven
into the fabric of your nation. But we
have these lofty standards,
most of them based on what we call
international law and which is of course
woven into European law. But
we call it international law, but we are
kind of
if you look at the West, we are kind of
an outlier here.
And now I'm turned to I turn to both
Raymond and and Omar. What about what
about the Middle East? Do they also
Middle Eastern countries do they also
have to let everyone in who is who is a
refugee? How how how does it work there?
I don't know. They're they are they
behave rather normally like most normal
people throughout historic history,
which is to say um
this is our land and
they wouldn't even begin to comprehend
this sort of conversation we're having
because it wouldn't make sense. They
would of course just be this is our
land, this is our way. We say who comes
in, we say who doesn't. And of course if
someone comes in with a wildly different
world view or culture that completely
clashes with theirs, they would have
absolutely no compunction.
>> embraced, right? Yeah.
Yeah.
So
and I think that's part of the reason
why
you know, that group of people from that
region which is broadly speaking the
Islamic world is tends to be an especial
thorn in Europe's side when they come as
migrants.
Because they too come with the very
heavy load and heavy laden world view,
cultural baggage tied up to the religion
which and you probably we probably don't
have time to get into the depth of it,
but basically long and short of it is
it's very antithetical to Western
civilization. And so when they come in
as as it was said earlier, this sort of
you know, human rights language is
basically being weaponized and exploited
by them. It's not the sort of language
they understand or that they would apply
to you going to their country, but they
see it as a weakness that we can
exploit, take advantage of and they do.
And the problem of course is that the
host society, the Western Europeans
don't seem to understand that. And I
think a lot of that is rooted in a in
all sorts of things, historical
ignorance, naivete, but also a bit of
arrogance because I think Western
Europeans think that their culture is
the culmination of human evolution,
which is to say secularism and they
think in due time everyone will
eventually slough off their religious
veneer and culture and assimilate.
But that's not happening. It's the exact
opposite and it seems to be that the
more the West liberalizes, if you will,
the more it actually repulses
Muslims and even non-Muslims, anyone
who's traditional.
So I think
that right there is one of the biggest
issues that few people
not us of course, but a lot a lot of the
people who are in charge don't
necessarily want to talk about or even
acknowledge. All this massive
immigration is not really making the
society younger, it's just making it
bigger. Now does it increase
fertility rate?
All these immigrants that are coming,
does it increase fertility rate? My
question is for Raymond and tell me if
this is a good or a bad thing.
The fertility rate of the migrants?
It's a great thing for them.
Not necessarily the host society.
But
you know, it's uh
if we talk about the the majority of the
migrants if we're talking about Europe
of course, they come from the
surrounding nations which just so happen
to be Islamic of course, all of North
Africa, all of the Middle East. And
there's a reason for that of course,
it's a historic reason. Those those
nations used to be part of what we would
call Europe, they were all Christian
lands
and just Europe was the last one that
wasn't conquered historically or at
least not all of it, portions of it
were. So the way I see it is what's
happening with the migration is just the
same thing that started from the very
beginning
with the Muslims invading and
appropriating. And I say that because
that's what they say. That's how they
describe it when I listen to them in
Arabic, when I read their literature,
when I watch you know sheikhs and
clerics talking, they present they even
call it you know, the
a demographic jihad. And of course the
word jihad you know, has this
connotation holy war, but all it really
means is to strive and struggle on
behalf of empowering Islam. And that can
be done any way, it doesn't have to be
physical.
>> So they actually preach this? They do.
Yeah, they they'll they'll tell the
women, you know, your job as a good
Muslima or a good Muslim woman is go and
have as many children with your husband
and men have have your four wives and
you know, just procreate and we will
drown them out. I mean there's literal
videos of them actually boasting about
this. So that's the problem. On the one
hand you have the Western mentality
which is just thinking about
humanitarianism and you know, just kind
of the material questions, economy,
numbers. On the other hand you have a
much more visceral civilization that is
doing whatever needs to do, that is
doing that's striving, engaged in jihad
even if it's legal. Having babies is not
illegal of course,
but if that's one of the ways they can
do it. And you know, the idea of
migration
actually traces all the way back to the
early years of Muhammad. So year one of
the Islamic calendar is is not the year
that Muhammad first got his revelations,
it's actually the year that he went on
what's called hijra. Hijra means
migration. And that's in the year 622 in
the Christian calendar. And what did he
do? He went he was basically
outnumbered, he was being according to
the story persecuted in Mecca and he
went and got accepted in Medina and then
he rose and essentially became a warlord
and then he ended up turning on the
people of Medina which included several
Jewish tribes and had them all beheaded.
And then you know, he consolidated his
power conquered and then
that's that was the blueprint and it
continued going on. Now most countries
of course would not take Muslims like
that in. Europeans fought very
violently, but that's always been an
option where hey, you let us come and
we'll we'll settle with you. You know,
the one video I'm thinking of where this
sheikh he he says we will give you
fertility and he's talking to you know,
Germans or Austrians and and British
people and he says you have no you're
not able to have babies, we'll bring
them for you and when the time comes we
will call them to the caliphate which is
obviously some kind of threat. And then
you look around and in all these major
capitals of Europe I don't know. I know
Oslo, maybe Brussels, the number one
newborn baby boy name is Muhammad. Okay,
that's I think that's very significant
and very telling. So it's happening and
to the Muslims it's just part of their
playbook and it's just kind of hey,
they're they're being stupid, we'll
exploit it, we'll take advantage. On the
other hand the Europeans for various
reasons are just not getting it and just
you know, playing playing dead.
The problem is that once
once people arrive
in any host society, if if they're what
I'm getting at is here is that once they
assimilate, once they integrate and then
once they assimilate, their birth rate
is going to be
kind of the same as the as the host
societies and if it isn't, that points
as for better or worse,
it points at integration failures and
the formation of
parallel societies. Now Raymond, you
you mentioned that uh
you know, making babies is not illegal.
Obviously.
But
what's
what's like when when people
think about parallel societies at least
in in a European context, what they
think about is terrorism. Oh, there's
going to be these are terrorist
incubators. One, two, lack of public
safety and and then we get to
rape and all other violent crimes. But
let's hold back a little bit and let's
assume that no one is going to explode
and rape anyone. What's the problem with
these enclave? Let's assume that they
don't break any law. Omar first.
Well, the problem was framed very well
in 2009 by Danish Social Democrats when
they said and framed the whole problem
in a in a to put it that way a Social
Democrat way. They said that the
Danish welfare system
is benefiting from the fact that the
society the member there's a very high
level among the members of the society.
It means that if somebody got gets
unemployed, the others are willing to
help him or her out because they know
that he will eventually get back to the
labor market because they're sharing the
same values, the same mental mindset and
so on. And the problem starts when
societies getting bit fragmented and
there are there's an increasing
member number of people who are not
sharing the basic values of the society.
Then the
average
Danish people can ask why should I pay
my tax money to hand out somebody who is
not willing to work, is not sharing my
values so on. Therefore, the Danes
introduced one of the
toughest
assimilation politics in whole Europe.
So I believe any sort of parallel
society and any sort of alternative
identities and the presence of these
alternative identities in a society
are eventually breaking the trust in the
society and European societies are built
on trust and on the communities.
Raymond.
Yeah, I agree. Um
it just as he was talking something came
to my mind which reminds me of the
entire theme of this conference which is
about borders and I'm reminded that
Samuel Huntington, he was a famous
political scientist, wrote his Clash of
Civilizations and he observed that all
around the Islamic world you have bloody
borders, which meant that wherever the
Muslim nations abutted next to a
non-Muslim nation, and sometimes another
Muslim nation, there was conflict and
violence. So, if that's the case on a
on a more macro level, what happens when
you take that demographic and put it
right in the middle of, let's say,
European London? Well, now you've
brought the now the this border conflict
is now right in the center of your
nation itself. And
again, it goes back to you were pointing
out like, let's say they don't engage in
violence and but they maintain their
parallel society. Well, what will
eventually happen is one is going to
subsume the other. You can't have
if we are using the Danish example or
any other European country and you have
a very growing Muslim demographic,
which, you know, is is committed. And
that's the thing, they have they show
solidarity. We just saw, I think, in
March 16th in London, where they were
engaged in Ramadan, breaking the fast,
and there were thousands of Muslims
making a show of solidarity. And once
again, all this is symbolic and
underscores the idea that we are a
people, not we are English. We, the
Muslims, are a people living amongst
you. And so, this is inherently, of
course, divisive and it even and and I
raise that point because there was no
violence, but it was another example of
just the sort of tribal mentality that
governs that particular demographic. And
it's just in the long and short of it,
as time progresses, of course, you will
have the violence, you will have the
parallel society, and one preying on the
other essentially, and exploiting and
taking advantage of human right laws and
so forth. And the other seems to be on
the retreat. Okay, so as time
progresses, if nothing changes and the
numbers are growing for the one, the
Muslim group, let's say, and the others
are shrinking, then eventually, even
without violence, and a lot of Muslims
themselves, they say this in in sermons,
that yeah, we will take over, just
simply as as like that, because
another issue we're not talking about is
we're looking at all the problems of the
migrants who are coming in, Muslim and
non-Muslim, I assume, but we're not
really talking about what are the
problems of the host societies that have
led to this, for example, such a low
birth rate, okay, amongst Europeans in
general. So, I think all of this has
created this symbiotic relationship
where one is just feeding on and
eventually overpowering and going to
take over the other.
When we are looking for when we are
looking for solutions. Now, I'm I'm
going to be a little bit of theoretical
here. Is it a good thing or is it a bad
thing that these people choose not to
participate in our societal
institutions? Because even though
even though
there are parties hunting for their
votes and I know that recently in the UK
this changed. Like this what I'm
describing is not true anymore in the
UK, but
traditionally, the left-wing parties,
the liberal parties, of course, are
hunting for these votes, but there is
not like, or at least not to my
knowledge, not like a Muslim party that
people vote for.
Is this a good thing or is this a bad
thing for for the majority society?
Well, I don't really believe that
Muslims can be united by the religion
alone because of the fault lines which
run is running between the communities.
If you take a look on the Netherlands,
for example, you see that there are much
more Dutch-Turkish intermarriages and
Dutch-Moroccan intermarriages than
Turkish-Moroccan intermarriages. So,
well, basically, they are the Muslim
brother and sister of each other. So,
why don't they unite? Because simply
they are not happy with each other. They
still have their very distinct identity.
And from time to another we hear news
about Muslim parties popping up in
Europe and they just basically
disappear. The There is one significant
exception. It happened also in the
Netherlands, where the Denk party
emerged basically and made it to the
parliament parliament. Basically, it was
historical period for the socialists.
The socialists used to take most of the
immigrant and Muslim votes in the
Netherlands. However, when the
socialists basically failed and lost
their support, the with Turkish
government support, the Denk party
emerged and they made it to the
parliament and managed somehow to get
the
big number of the Muslim votes. However,
we see that their popularity is
shrinking because
most of the Muslims are
basically looking after their financial
interests and they find they're finding
these financial and individual interest
with the left. Basically, in the in
Europe, historically speaking, it were
the unions those rallied up these people
when they were invited as guest workers
or came from previous former colonies.
Later on, it was mostly the left-wing
governments those provided citizenship
and family unification. Therefore, there
is this affiliation and we see that
members of the Muslim communities who
make it to the universities are
naturally siding with the left wing and
with left-wing organizations because
this is the way they find their social
mobility there.
Increasingly, it is the
green movement and parties who are
gaining most of the Muslim votes. So,
and this is a tendency which is quite
obvious, especially in France. We see
that Melenchon is now getting more and
more Muslim votes and the
left-wing party is getting more and more
banlieue party, so a party of the
suburbs, mostly of Muslim immigrants.
Still back to your question, I don't
really think religion unifies them
because, well, I'm following the Muslim
discourses in Europe and the
intra-Muslim discourses and I just see
that they are hating each other's guts.
And they will be very happy to have any
partner just to finish off their local
rivals because
they're like full of They They have lots
of identities and these identities are
dividing them, but still something is
unifies them that, well, from a majority
society perspective, of course, that
a big number of these people are not
sharing basic European
values. Therefore, they are not
integrating to society enough and many
of them are not willing to contribute to
the societies.
Raymond, how do you see this?
I agree and disagree. I agree on the one
hand that, you know, Muslim groups,
as you're saying, they're different
ethnicities and they often do clash and
not get along. It's not a monolithic
thing. But that's only if you put them
together and they're the only two. Yeah,
of course, they fight. But once you put
them in a host European society, then
the differences start to actually blend
away and they become they see more
commonalities. So, it's it's both, I
would think. And also the idea that just
just by being Muslim, that is a strong
impetus to not assimilate. So, that's
one more thing they all have in common.
And you know, there's actual whole
teachings and doctrines in Islam about
how we're we're part of the ummah, it
doesn't matter what nation you're from,
the ummah is all that matters, and so
forth. So, you definitely have the
hardcore types who think that way and
preach that way. So, I do think they
are, to one extent, as a body, you can
speak generically about Muslims with the
caveat that was introduced, which is
basically, yeah, but the the more you
dig in and you realize there's different
ethnicities and different factions, they
can too be fractured. But when it's all
said and done, it sort of doesn't matter
because all of them, whether it's almost
I mean, what we're saying is basically
they
if they're fighting amongst each other,
what do you expect how do they feel
towards the infidel, the host society?
Okay, so it's almost like it's just a
turbulent force that sometimes is is
angry and and or has conflict with the
host society and then angry and has
conflicts with its own sources, which
goes back to that Samuel Huntington
quote, because the second part is he
said um he said Islam's borders are
bloody and its inwards, too. Okay, so um
that that sort of demographic is what I
I guess what I'm trying to say is it's
so different in its worldview than the
than the forces that have shaped
modern-day Europe, culminating with the
concept of humanism and humanitarianism,
that, you know, it's just it's really
like oil and water. You try to put them
together and you end up having conflict.
Of course, it doesn't always have to be
this way and there are, of course, many
Muslims who are more concerned about
their their material being and their
financial and economic situation. I'm
not discounting that, either. But it's
it's a mixed bag of fun.
So, would you like to ask a question?
Yeah, I would.
It's very fascinating. It reminds me the
discourse reminds me of something Well,
first, the comment that was made over
here about
like earlier the earlier session about
like how can we make more
Christians have more children and have
Muslims have less children. And
there was an observation of a political
scientist at Harvard, a Jennifer
Hochschild, and she said that a lot of
conservatives and
people on the right seem to actually
share a lot of values with a lot of
immigrants. And at least on the terms of
cultural conservatism, social
conservatism. And it seems to me that
like I'm almost wondering if there's
something you can learn from the Muslim
immigrants
and
in terms of what what they're kind of
bringing bringing in
because, you know, you spoke about,
yeah, they they they have a conflict
with each other, but I'm also hearing
that there's a lot of conflict within
Europe, too, about the direction, the
demographic direction in terms of social
values, cultural values. I'm pretty sure
that they are not confused about the
number of genders, for example.
That's something we could learn from.
>> that's what I mean. I mean, I don't
think I
I think that that that in that sense
there's kind of an alignment. And so
this is one of I think one of the
interesting tensions or paradoxes
that there's actually a lot of common
common ground. And I'm sort of curious
how you how you think about that. So
actually we can learn from them how to
not let anyone in. Raymond already
mentioned that.
Anything else? This is this is actually
an interesting question. It is an
interesting question and and there is
much to learn from the Muslims and it's
basically those components of their
culture that are common sensical and
normal and that humanity all across the
board once participated in. So these are
not things that are necessarily a
byproduct of Islamic culture.
You that you gave the perfect example.
They're not confused about genders. They
know what a man is and they know what a
woman is as one example. So I what I'm
saying ultimately is that they seem this
seems appealing and it seems something
almost inherent to Islam but it's really
not. It's just what how humans
throughout history up until very
recently thought. Except and they still
think this way. It's not even just
Muslims. If you look at the other
civilizations Chinese
Japanese Indian civilizations, they also
operate according to common sense and
what's in it what's good for me and my
people. Okay, so I think that is one
thing that the West has completely lost
sight of. Um basically they lost sight
of the forest for the trees as it were
because they're just caught up with all
these other isms and constructs and I
mean we can watch I can go watch um in a
congressional panel where scientists
don't know how to answer the question
what is a woman. Okay?
That's not going to be a problem for any
other civilization whatsoever. So their
strength again it's not something
inherent. It's just I guess they haven't
been so corrupted and compromised. Um
but luckily it doesn't mean we have to
become Muslim. It just means we have to
stop being compromised and just reclaim
some sanity I think. Mhm. Omar. If So
when we're No. Ladies first. If I can
add if I can add dance to answer your
question what to do promote
Christianity.
That's my answer. That's I really
strongly believe worship I'm one I'm
also belonging to the worship group
myself. Uh preach preach
share your testimonies about how God
touch your life and help you. But that's
the thing I think I I used to be a
teacher also. So we should impose that
to educational system. Teach kids that
makes Christianity attractive and make
it joyful because when you worship it's
joyful activity for the youth. I mean to
make it to make it attraction. This is
my another goal to make it attractive.
Uh so that we can kind of become
stronger with the our own belief system
with our own religion and so show for
the Muslims.
You know. I would if I can just add to
that because I agree with you completely
and that's the other problem. The West
because it's lost its Christian mooring
has created a vacuum. And that's why
things that are normal in religions
including Islam seem appealing and weird
and people want to gravitate to but it
was always there in their own heritage
in their own religion but it's been
beaten down and sort of dismantled and
just bringing that back as you say would
fill that void and all of a sudden the
the good things that you see in Islam
would just be normal things that we have
plenty of ourselves.
>> Because Muslims tend to be proactive. So
our goal is to make Christians proactive
as well. Like to balance. At least.
Thank you so much for inspiring
conversation. My name is Wakai Keda. I'm
a journalist from Tokyo and I'll be
speaking
the panel tomorrow on the family. So
um
Japan is an interesting case in this
conversation. We have one of the lowest
uh shares of foreign nationals
among the developed countries.
Around 3% of the total population.
So now the current government has taken
a clear position. Demographic decline
will be addressed through a structured
foreign worker program not immigration.
Um so the current plan sets an
acceptance cap of around 8 million
foreign workers by 2050 which is about
uh 8% of Japanese total population.
So my question is do you think that
distinction
um between the
maintaining temporary workers and
immigrants
uh
is sustainable in practice?
And more broadly is there a point which
the scale of a foreign national I mean
population begins to reshape uh
society's cultural identity
regardless of legal category people
arrive under?
I think we may have stumbled upon
another thing that we can learn from
from Muslims which is
how to make it sure that the the guest
workers don't stay and they bring their
own
tribe
to our country but I will allow our
speakers to answer.
Well yeah there's a lot of countries
prime among them Saudi Arabia our great
good good good friend that I like.
They're very strict about you can't just
go have get become a citizen or anything
like that. You have to come in and
you're just a worker and you're treated
like a worker. Some of them say we're
treated like slaves. You can't have a
church if they find you in a in a
makeshift church celebrating you get
arrested. And this has happened multiple
times. And that's just one extreme
example Saudi Arabia. So that's an
example of a country that takes its
cultural
mores so seriously and doesn't want any
outside interference. Now I maybe I can
argue that's a little extreme that sort
of model but as you can see it's so
diametrically opposed to where we're at
you know. So something in the middle a
happy balance I think is a little more
logical.
Bring back the
Bring back
and the
righteousness.